get to audience questions.
I love this first one because it's something
I've thought about for a very, very long time.
Really, since I first became engaged in politics
when I was in high school.
The question is, Hey David, how could anyone,
it will be undecided about whether or not
they're going to vote for Donald Trump.
I also want to know how this is possible and
it seems to me that there's a few different
things going on.
I mean, I actually want to know how is it
possible to really be a swing voter?
Do they not know or pay attention to what
the parties and candidates represent?
Are they voting based on personalities or
physical appearance or something else?
It is never really made sense to me and I
think that there's a couple of different things
going on.
First of all, a lot of these swing voters
are uninformed and I, I'm not saying this
as a pejorative, we've seen, we've analyzed
in fact a lot of interviews with voters who,
one was with a group of women who said, I
voted Obama in 2012 and then I voted Trump
in 2016 they were clueless.
I mean they didn't know anything about what
was going on.
So I think part of it is that they are unaware
of the facts and probably making decisions
on the basis of rhetoric that they are not
then researching the truth of a, they are
falling for the talking points of one versus
the other.
I don't think it's particularly good for our
society.
I mean, listen, I'd rather between Obama and
Trump, I'm voting for Obama as a society.
I don't know that we're better off for people
falling for either candidates or either parties
talking points in terms of what it means about
critical thinking and the ability to analyze
assertions for yourself.
But there, there is that element, first and
foremost, people who just don't really know
what's going on.
Um, there's another thing though that I think
needs to be mentioned when we talk about,
uh, the undecideds and the swing voters and
the independence, which is there is a sort
of psychological pleasure that some people
get by being the enlightened centrist.
And you see there are actually some, uh, media
people who have YouTube channels or whatever
based on the idea that they are independent
and they are centrists and they will sometimes
vote for Republicans and sometimes vote for
Democrats.
Is it possible that someone's ideology might
sometimes point to voting for a Republican
and other times point to voting for a Democrat?
Absolutely.
It's more common in very local races.
It's much less common.
For example, at the Senate level, I'm sure
we can find examples, uh, where you have,
you know, a very, uh, a Democrat that's conservative
on issues you disagree with them on.
And a Republican who is more liberal, for
example, on issues where you agree, so you
might vote for the Republican.
These are very rare cases.
So I've met a lot of people who get some kind
of a satisfaction from sort of feeling as
though they are above the peons who are on
the left or on the right, Democrats or Republicans.
But I actually think it's often they who are
the ignorant ones because they seem to, uh,
uh, they, they seem to interpret centrism
as being more discerning and more fact based
when it comes to deciding who to vote for
when in reality they're missing that the differences
between Republicans and Democrats left and
right.
The differences are so obvious that to be
the enlightened centrist is the furthest thing
from enlightened that you could possibly be.
So I think that that's also a part of it is
the combination of some people who are uninformed,
some people who like the idea of just being
contrarian and saying, I'm, I'm a different
thing.
I'm not like you guys.
And I'm not like you guys.
I'm just the, I'm the centrist.
I sometimes about this way.
Sometimes the other way, everyone that I've
personally talked to, and this is merely anecdotal,
when you ask them about their politics, their
politics actually make it very clear.
You should always voting for a Democrat or
you should always have been voting for a Republican.
You just don't seem to realize it for yourself.
Uh, it's, it's a sort of a sad commentary
about education, um, in the United States.
You then also have voters who are just not
very politically engaged and they like to
say, I vote for whoever is best in a particular
election.
And very often that has nothing to do with
policy at all.
It actually is personality and um, the way
that the person campaigns and sort of a feeling
that someone gets judged that as you will
in terms of whether that's a good thing or
not a good thing.
But yeah, I also don't really understand,
I mean, listen, if today if someone is unsure
whether they are voting for a Democrat or
Trump, I want to hear from you.
Even the furthest right Democrat, which I
guess would be who's furthest, right?
I mean, is it like a Biden of the people that
are still in it?
Biden followed by Buddha judge, I guess of
the people that are, that are still in the
running or the furthest right.
Of course, I'm voting for them over Donald
Trump.
And I would be very interested to hear during
live calls from someone who might vote for
Trump or might vote for a Democrat.
I want to hear on what issue is it that is
keeping you from deciding